i told my mom i'm absolutely
over the moon that nobody took me
seriously in the beginning
how many screenplays have you written
i have lost count
i have lost count um
more than 50
more than 50. i can say that
feature screenplays or a mixture of
shorts and features
um no those are those will be all
features mixture of features mixture of
pilots you know
when did you write your first feature
screenplay
maybe about
18 19.
and it was
it was called audacious
was the name of it and nobody understood
like what is this and i had to explain
what audacious meant and
uh
but it was a vampire script yeah
oh okay and you were in georgia at the
time i was in georgia yeah okay and
i i think at that time i hadn't learned
the importance of of titles you know
titles have to be strong and
understandable
and have sometimes a couple of different
meanings
you know they can't just be
self-indulgent
you know
and uh everything i wrote had some
weird thing that i learned um
but that was by far the weirdest title i
think i came up with which was audacious
what does it actually mean to live
vicariously through someone or something
like a parasite oh okay yeah interesting
codependency yeah oh okay okay
and that's really what it was about
about this vampire needing this guy to
come to fruition you know
to come to be
what was your writing process like on
that first screenplay
making sure
uh
that the names were indented properly
and you know making sure spacing was
appropriate and the proper font was
being used i was it was so much still a
learning process of just what went into
writing us a screenplay
um
from a
formatting standpoint not a story
structure standpoint
so at that point i hadn't even gotten
into
really into the craft
it was still very much just how do i
make this look professional
so
how long did it take you to finish that
screenplay oh
five days
oh wow okay five days in the beginning i
wrote screenplays
in a week or less
in a week because i didn't know what i
didn't know
like once you understand what the craft
really is and how you
how you get how you move an audience the
way you need to move them how do you get
out information without it being very
convoluted or heavy-handed how do you
how do you get information across both
in text and subtext like once you start
getting into that and story structure
it's
it complicates things and there's no way
that you're writing a script in a week
and if you do
and it reads very well i'm i'm impressed
i'm impressed because there's a lot of
work that goes into it
just in terms of just outlining takes me
about a week or more
just outlining it just to understand
what's going on in a very like one page
kind of way it takes a while so back
then i didn't know that so you when you
don't know what you don't know you just
you plow right through it like i'm done
you drop it on the desk
and for some reason i think i think it's
all because the industry was so
new to georgia in the in the late 90s
you know early 2000s like late 90s
really and that's where i really started
to
you know get a lot of work and i'm
turning in and stuff
that agent i don't i knew that he'd
certainly
represented other writers and
but i don't i don't think he ever
represented anybody who was
successful
because there's no way you could if you
were receiving those kind of screenplays
and just being like whoa
whoa that's awesome there was no
structure i look back sometimes on some
of the things i've written like what was
i thinking and it's just because you you
didn't know
you don't know what you don't know
and so you're you're constantly learning
every time and especially when you seek
knowledge and you you don't have
that vanity to believe that you're the
best at something
i never believe that i'm the best at
anything other than being me that that's
really it and i'm even sometimes i'm
struggling with that right so so i'm
constantly looking at ways to improve
and as i began to understand story
structure and stuff like that my stories
got better but it took a while for me to
get to the place where i am now where i
feel
i feel
as though
i'm creating very
um
complete stories
you know where you don't feel at the end
like what no i'm just missing something
i just can't figure out what it is you
know i feel like my stories are very
complete now i feel they tell a complete
story
and
all the arcs are completed and they're
completed skillfully
i'm always just looking to
figure out how to write a better
script the next time how do i how do i
write a better script the next time
and then i start okay i did this last
time
what do i improve but what didn't i know
that i know now and
you know and that's how you continue to
grow
but back then
script in a week was nothing
do you think it would have helped if you
had this delusion where you thought your
thing was the greatest or your writing
was the greatest you know some people
they're able to convince everybody to
that somehow i don't know i know people
like that i know people like that and
and don't get me wrong i don't mean i
know people like that who don't work i
know people like that who are working
and
some of the conversations i've heard
have been hilarious
because this person
has i think in the arts because it is
it is so much it is so personal even if
it's supposed to be business it's really
personal
you create something it came from you
you birthed it right
and then you hear somebody look at two
pages and go that's garbage what else
you got
you you either have to be able to accept
it
and say that's not for them
or
you become calloused and you become
you develop a sense of an inflated ego
and i think that if you if you develop
the inflated ego which i think is the
go-to
you you start stunting your growth as a
matter of fact i'd venture to say you
start regressing because when the going
gets tough you're going to fall back on
the things you know and you've never
bothered to learn anything new you're
just going to fall back on the things
that you think have worked
and
i see that a lot in the industry i don't
think that's helpful at all i think i
think it's to your detriment
and when i say detriment i don't mean
detriment in terms of of your your
marketability i i mean in terms of your
true ability to grow and become your
best you i think it's i think it's uh
it's detrimental
with autis did you ever try to sell it
yes
sadly
the the agent did try to sell it and you
know he tried very hard and i don't
blame anybody from not for not buying it
as a matter of fact
i have told this to
[Music]
everyone including my mom who thinks i'm
the absolute best i told my mom i'm
absolutely
over the moon that nobody took me
seriously in the beginning
because if they had and i had made any
of the number of screenplays that i had
written in the in the past in my in the
very beginning
they would have laughed me out of here
and i would have never gotten another
job
i think i would have never reached a
point where i felt as though i could
take you know my career into my own
hands i never would have gotten there
because i think at that age if that
happens to you you're done
i think you're done
if somebody if somebody cuts your legs
off at 20
i think your legs are just gone
i think you don't have the stomach for
it i see too many people that come to la
and they think they're going to be
and then they get their legs cut out
from under them and they go back to
where they came from
and they are no longer interested in the
business at all
so i'm very fortunate that nobody took
me serious except that one agent
very serious i mean
i think everything happened exactly how
it was supposed to
i on the one assignment that i was sent
out on and taken seriously and it was
through a sample not from me
writing anything for that specific pilot
it was just from a sample of my writing
in general
and that's how i was on you know young
americans but
if it had can you imagine if i if they
had wanted a submission like so a tv
show i'd written and i submitted
something it was like yeah here take a
look at this
get out of here
that's what would have happened it was
too green
i didn't know enough
so